لك وانوه مشاهدينا الى هذا الخبر العاجل
على شاشتنا عن مراسل الجزيره اربع غارات
اسرائيليه تستهدف بلده الخيام ومحيطها
جنوبي لبنان وهذه الصور تظهر اثار هذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه وهي اربع غارات كما
ذكرنا تستهدف بلده الخيام ومحيطها جنوب
لبنان نار تصاعدا لاعمده
الدخان
وا في اطار هذا التصعيد
المتبادل في منطقه جنوب لبنان وشمال
اسرائيل وسنكون بعد قليل مع مراسلينا من
جنوب لبنان وشمال اسرائيل للحديث اكثر عن
هذا التصعيد الغاره
الثانيه اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي
تتابعونها وصلتنا قبل قليل وهي من منطقه
الخيام التي تعرضت كما ذكرنا لاربع غارات
اسرائيليه استهدفت البلده ومحيطها جنوب
لبنان ونرى تصاعدا لاعمده الدخان بعد
تنفيذ هذه
الغارات اربع غارات نرى هنا الصور من
زاويه اخرى من الواضح ان الاستهدافات كانت
قويه بالنظر الى سحب الدخان المتصاعده
الكثيفه في سماء هذه المنطقه طبعا هذه
الغارات تاتي في ظل تصاعد التوتر على
الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل ينفذ غرا